it's time for tonight's scene and unseen
segment where we expose the stories
behind the headlines
and for that we turn to author of the
spider
who saved christmas fox news contributor
raymond arroyo raymond
a number of bureaucrats have been
invoking santa when they discussed their
covet rules
remember michigan governor gretchen
whitmer
does anyone have a question for santa
claus
santa do you have to wear a mask when
i'm in my workshop
with all my elves we all are mashed up
in social distancing they also also say
hand sanitizer if you're done with the
cookies and milk
that was a good suggestion another way
to stay safe during the
holiday is to stay home
but call your grandparents and your
cousins
and your family so jesse stay away from
your family this christmas kids
i find this so disgusting i mean the
governor is using santa claus here to
indoctrinate children jesse
and normalize her culvert restrictions
what other things will santa and the
elves be doing next
reducing their carbon footprint by
turning off the heat and biking to
deliver presents
maybe they'll sign on to the iranian
nuclear pact i mean this is insidious
as buddy the elf would say you sit on a
throne of lies
that's what i would tell the good
governor this is really sick watching
my parents might not want to see me on
christmas but that's a whole nother
story
dr anthony fou though he appears on
sesame street
and a bunch of characters are there and
it's on cnn and he's talking to kids
about santa and vaccines
i want you to react to this elba's
friend
has a question about santa claus santa
still be able to
visit me in corona viruses season
well i have to say i took care of that
for you because i was worried that you'd
all be upset
so what i did a little while ago i took
a trip up there to the north pole
i went there and i vaccinated santa
claus myself
i measured his level of immunity and he
is good to go
jesse i hate to say this but dr fauci is
either forgetting himself or just
lying because on november 22nd when
asked if santa could spread covet
fauci told usa today this
santa is
a lot of good innate immunity so if
santa has innate immunity
why is he lying about giving santa a
vaccine in the north pole
children need to know because i know the
real santa he survived the spanish flu
yellow fever sars a couple of world wars
he will come this christmas
and he's not going to get coveted which
is a good thing because fauci
hasn't been off tv long enough jesse to
get to the north pole
so if dr fauci keeps telling fibs he's
going to end up on the naughty list
oh all right taking a heart
that's right coal in his stocking all
right
raymond this is driving me crazy a
number of politicians have received the
covid vaccine over the last few days
including aoc
over the weekend and joe biden got it
today
now i don't mind politicians modeling
the safety of the vaccine
but everybody says no they should they
should wait they should wait until
everybody that's
old gets vaccinated do you agree or not
well i'm going to tell you i i split a
little bit from you on this
the the cdc says the vulnerable and
frail elderly should be first
so i defend joe biden and nancy pelosi
getting the vaccine
immediately right but marco rubio and
aoc
we should be giving this vaccine to
teachers jesse yes
the teachers need it now because look at
the damage this is doing to kids
not having in-person learning they need
to be in the classroom
vaccinate the teachers take away this
excuse i mean the kids can barely pass
it along to teachers anyway
the data shows us that inoculate them
get the schools open again
we need that i think i think they're
just saying look how safe it is
this is a little public service
announcement not that big of a deal but
here's a big deal raymond
the house has passed this 900 billion
dollar stimulus deal
raymond's been looking into some of
these nuggets that they slid
in under there it's gonna drive you
crazy
go ahead jesse no matter what vaccine is
in their systems none of these
politicians apparently
were immune to pork while 284 billion
goes to ppp loans
for small businesses and six hundred
dollars go to individuals
there's also this 10 million for gender
programs
in pakistan oh my god funds to address
gender inequality among statues
193 million so federal hiv aids workers
abroad
can buy new cars 40 million dollars for
the kennedy center i guess so pelosi and
pals can go see
you know hello dolly 1.5 million for the
appropriations committee's office of
diversity and inclusion
and a bill that mandates new hiring
measures to ensure diversity
in the intelligence community raymond i
just want to know
unbelievable what is a gender program
what is the gender program but you know
what it almost doesn't matter because
it's in pakistan
what does that have to do with it right
what does it have to do with relief here
in america
but the gender of statues maybe mrs
roberty lee will have a shot because the
general just got moved out of the
capitol so
we'll see i guess they tore a bunch of
statues down maybe they're gonna
spend some money putting them up but
they're gonna be the right gender i
guess
all right raymond i'm gonna check up on
yeah yeah get back to us on the gender
of these new statues